bonjour monsieur frédéric fisbach selon
vous ce qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement et ce qui a été fait sur le
terrain n'est pas assez oui entre entre
les annonces qui ont été faites et ce
qu'on voit au cra se retrouver sur sur
le terrain il ya vraiment une dissonance
entre un engagement fort de la part du
gouvernement dans ses annonces et en
réalité les enfin les moyens qui vont
être mis en oeuvre
le fonds d'indemnisation spécifique pour
les travailleurs victimes dit
coronavirus ne sera pas créée mais
locaux vides 19 pourrait être reconnu
comme maladie professionnelle est ce un
moyen pour le gouvernement de détourner
l'attention
non parce que c'était réellement une
annonce qu'il avait fait de la
reconnaissance du vide 19 comme maladie
professionnelle
bien que c'est quelque chose qu'on était
dans la tente les modalités qui sont
prévues par le projet de décret qui a
été présenté bien qu'alain dans le sens
de la cftc demandait on se retrouve
quand même avec beaucoup de déception à
la fois pour les soignants étant donné
que les tableaux qui sont créées ne
prendrons en compte que les infections
respiratoires graves liés à cette
maladie là alors qu'on n'a pas encore
d'études épidémiologiques exactement sur
les conséquences qui pourraient en
notamment des conséquences neurologiques
que des atteintes rénales ou autre pour
les non soignant une deuxième déception
un parce que ben les tableaux sont
accessibles aux soignants et toute la
procédure hors tableau qui devait être
facilité selon olivier vais rentrer dans
un communiqué de presse du 30 juin ne
sont pas facilités dans le sens où ils
doivent solliciter la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie
ils avaient dit qu'ils auraient pas un
taux minimum pour la reconnaissance hors
tableau alors qu'ils ont quand même
encore laisser le taux d'incapacité
permanente de 25%
donc c'est vrai que beaucoup de salariés
vont passer à côté et on reste encore
que sur les affections respiratoires
pour les personnels
non soignants justement on sait que les
soigneurs été en première ligne durant
cette crise yeux coronavirus est ce qu
on a eu tendance à oublier d'autres
professions essentiels à la vie de la
nation pendant cette période
ben en faisait dans une reconnaissance
que pour les soignants sur tableau on
oublie tous les professionnels qui ont
continué de faire vivre la nation
notamment les personnes qui étaient dans
l'est dans les commerces alimentaires
notamment les personnes qui continuent à
faire vivre aussi au niveau de la
sécurité et des autres éléments c'est
vrai qu'elle a tous ces personnels là
qui sont oubliés par le tableau était
comme le disait aux soignants donc quand
on dit soignants c'est tous les
personnels des établissements de santé
et médico sociale l'aide à domicile
toute une branche a aussi été oubliés
notamment les salariés des particuliers
employeurs qui ont continué à prendre en
charge des personnes dépendantes ceux là
sont complètement oublié aussi de de
sabodola et les entreprises de services
à la personne pour ceux en tout cas qui
suivit des personnes dépendantes et
c'est vraiment dommageable dans dans
cette annonce qui était forte en en
disant qu'on va reconnaître le coc vite
comme maladie professionnelle
mais ça va être que sur ses atteintes
respiratoires pour les soignants et pour
les autres ça risque d'être compliqué
parce que 25 % de taux d'incapacité
ils sont souvent difficilement
atteignable dans certains cas et surtout
pour solliciter cette commission ça
c'est vraiment moi on est plus que déçu
on est même un peu remonté contre ce
projet de décret qui va pas assez loin à
notre vie merci beaucoup
frédéric fisbach d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général fédération cftc et
sentait